the hits just keep coming for a Lisa
bloom a report by the New York Times
says the liberal super PAC American
bridge for some reason paid Lisa bloom
two hundred thousand dollars to solicit
sexual misconduct allegations against
Donald Trump mark Stein is an author and
columnist and something an expert on
ethics he joins us tonight is this I
mean I don't know if you're a
professional at this torn I don't know
if you're representing the Bar
Association and you say this but what am
I to make of Lisa bloom taking 200 grand
in order to dig up dirt on a political
candidate yeah I mean I wouldn't say I
was a professional ethicist and I'm not
sure which bars Lisa bloom and her
mother bill lot Gloria Allred belong to
but there are different incentives at
work here and loyal more than almost any
other profession owes the client honest
services and if you have the set up that
these two are engaged in where they've
been fishing fishing essentially for
Stooges that they can put up as to
damage the President to get the so they
can be sitting there at press
conferences as they've been doing for
most of lives then I think there is
actually something malodor us about it
bothers me if she were political
consultant or just a conventional
slip-and-fall ambulance chaser you sort
of know what you're getting but she
poses as in his and is represented as by
the press is some sort of moral leader
who's fighting on behalf of things that
are good and true light against darkness
but she's not she's a totally cynical
transactional sleazy lawyer well yes I
mean you you mentioned a couple of weeks
ago Tucker that she'd she was originally
Harvey Weinstein's lawyer and then and
then they fell out and she was no longer
his lawyer now I I don't have a problem
with that because I actually think it's
sometimes helpful and I've done this
myself to have a lawyer who is not on
your side ideologically and actually
just just looks at the case from the
point of the law and so it's sometimes
actually helpful
it might be helpful to have a feminist
lawyer actually representing a scummy
sleazebag who assaults women everybody
is entitled to a good defense
what made it sleazy was that she had a
bob deal with Harvey Weinstein he was
making a television production of her
book that's what that's sleazy there are
ethical rules determining when lawyers
embark on business relationships with
their clients and if you look at Lisa
bloom and her mother for example one of
the reasons they've been trying to raise
they're raising money one of the aspects
of this is that if you if they manage to
place an interview with the television
network that pays for the interview the
lawyer gets 1/3 of the fee as a
commission now that's a lawyer serving
as an agent and it's may well not be in
the clients interest particularly if
you're just some ordinary woman who
happens to have been sexually assaulted
by a powerful man it may not actually be
in your interest to be going on
television becoming a famous person when
in the end Lisa bloom goes on to the
next client and you're living with the
consequences of having become a briefly
famous person but still with no money or
celebrity or enduring fame to show for
it in the clients interest right so
she's just a parasite like so many
lawyers can we can we agree though in
the end that I don't have to take any
more moral lectures from Lisa bloom oh
no absolutely I mean what is interesting
to me about this is the she she is
explicitly saying that she wants money
to help take down the president so you
know you're not giving to a PAC you're
not giving to a cause you're basically
enriching Lisa bloom to advance her
political objectives and and and as I
said the the particular women in this
issue
in this case I just essentially just
ventriloquist's puffles she switched the
hand up the back of the dress and makes
them say what they say and and as I said
a couple of minutes ago for as long as I
can remember I've switched on the TV and
Lisa bloom or her mother has been
sitting there next to a woman to whom
something bad has happened and you never
hear from the woman again and Lisa bloom
and Gloria always go on to riches and
riches and ashes
the only woman Lisa bloom is helping is
Lisa bloom oh great to see you